with flags at half-mast and heavy
security outside public buildings France
is again on edge after an apparent
Islamist attack killed two police
employees it's what they had all dreaded
taro during the Euro Cup and Friends
security for is already fully stretched
after all the country has been in a
state of emergency for over six months
now on top of that nationwide protests
have been going on since the beginning
of the year against the government's
labor reforms on Tuesday thousands of
demonstrators again took to the streets
French security forces had their hands
full there to become also to a fatiguer
the police are starting to get tired
they've been in action since the January
2015 attacks on Charlie Hebdo then with
last November's attacks we really had to
mobilize everything we had we're just
not able to cope with all of this a vaca
more Without Borders your address on now
of course there is also euro 2016 with
over a million fans coming from abroad
100,000 security forces have been
deployed more than ever before oh it's
been good fun we haven't seen any
trouble there police have been good to
us the locals been good to us so it's
been it's been a really good time and we
haven't felt unsafe whatsoever we pit we
felt really safe here of course to think
about it I mean you think twice before
you go out you think twice before you go
to the induce the metro for example we
took the cab here because we wouldn't we
want didn't want to go to the Metro if
you go with the intention that you're
going to feel on the pressure you're not
going to enjoy yourself like the world
goes on you just can't give in to these
so-called crazy people
protests hooligans and terror Frances
security forces are working at full
capacity
you